round 11 of the US and US Women's Chess  Championships here in st. Louis the  tension reached a fever pitch as four  players came into the last day dreaming  of winning a national title  papiano Caruana kept his hopes alive  with a victory against Alexander onus  shook but it was Sam Shanklin who scored  a dominating win to be crowned u.s.  champion in the biggest accomplishment  of his career teen sensation anyway  finally lost her first game of the  tournament to last year's champion  sabina for zur which sets up an exciting  matchup with na z pi kids e to close out  and already dramatic events it's time to  decide who will be the queen of us chess  for 2018 rapid playoffs for all the  marbles coming up next  you